I think it's important to have something
that's beneath the surface.
Otherwise you're writing essentially
an elaborate diary entry.
Um,
I think profundity is in the eye of the
beholder.
Um,
some of my,
some of the essays I get that were
eliminated from the collection,
there were a couple of them that I
decided not to include because they
didn't have enough and,
or any universal application,
you know,
what was me,
I got a parking ticket or you know,
some boy was mean to me and no one,
particularly carers,
but uh,
you can make people care about small,
significant details and sort of lend the
entire universe to a tiny detail.
You know,
there's this sort of like themed and
Buddhist Meditation Practice where
you're supposed to picture the entire
world on the head of a pin,
you know,
and I feel like the only kind of
meditation or stillness or non neuroses
it's ever made any sense to me.
Um,
and that's sort of what the essays try
to do.
Um,
you know,
some of the critiques have been at,
some of them don't do that,
that some of them read a little bit too
casual.
I think when you're writing personal
essays,
it's,
it can be difficult to suss out,
uh,
what seems profound to you because they,
it's not necessarily intellectually
profound,
sort of emotionally profound.
So if you're just sort of coming through
it,
you know,
it's what speaks to or,
or what,
what does,
it's funny,
I've spent I guess about seven years
in total encouraging my author is not to
pay too much attention to the critics.
That all press is good press.
You know,
book publicity is very different than
any other kind of publicity.
And the fact that I have friends who
work in music and film publicity and
it's much more defensive whereas ours is
much more,
you know,
please God Mr. Short story writer,
go commit a felony so I can get you some
press.
It's very difficult.
And,
uh,
so just to be written about,
and then is,
it is a feat in itself.
And then I guess you kind of worry about
the tone second.
Um,
and I think I have luckily taken a
little bit of that to heart.
Um,
the criticism hasn't been too harsh or I
don't see it because they're personal
essays.
I think if I let it all in thoroughly,
it would be a critique of me as a human
being.
So it's very easy to look at it and
think,
you know,
a lot of the book reviews have been
assigned to people who are slightly
younger or my age.
And you know,
I,
I have been sort of more interested to
see the reviews by reviewers who I know
have been doing it for a while and are
really reviewing it as a book as opposed
to a extended diary entry that they
could have written if only they had had
a couple of more red balls after work,
you know,
so it's,
it's pretty easy to slough off,
but I think it's important to some of
it.
And um,
and some of it's been really helpful.
I didn't expect that.
I expected just to be worried about
getting press and,
and hopefully getting the book out there
and getting people aware of it.
And,
and some of the critiques have been
actually really useful.
Also.
That was a pleasant surprise.